I think next year thus hours may finally
be in line to just blow up the whole tax
system I'm Nicholas be with reason TV
and today we're talking with the wall
street journal Steve more Steve thanks
for talking to me the economy is going
to be the major issue one way or the
other what are the types of policies I
mean part of the problem with Mitt
Romney there's a lot of meat to ism he
likes stimulus but not as much as Obama
he liked art but not as much as Obama he
supported in Auto ballot not as much as
Obama what does he need to do to really
separate himself from Obama and this is
the clincher things that would actually
help the economy well as you know I've
spent a lot of time in politics I run
the club for growth for six or eight
years so I my view of elections is
elections are almost always referendum
on the incumbent and I do believe that
when people go into the election booth
in November we're going to ask one
question can we really afford four more
years of this and there is so in terms
of who's going to win I genuinely
believe that is unknowable right now
people say oh robin is going to win by
five points or that it's just there's
too many variables that are undecided
right now but it is true this is a lousy
economy this has been the weakest
recovery we've ever seen but Obama's
line is very compelling to people look
without me we would have had a great
depression and you know I took over from
these failed Bush policies so I think
it's going to be I do think it's going
to be a very close race I think it's
going to be decided by one or two
percentage points and the question is
whether people feel confident that
Obama's policies can lead to growth I
think that there will be a catastrophe
and I also believe that for a second
what why are they so catastrophic I mean
give us the thumbnail Obama you know
he's got a coherent theory whether it
maps the world is a different thing but
it's like we need the government to
prime the pump to keep demanda i think
that the primary problem with barack
obama is that he is a doctrinaire
leftist who never who doesn't really
understand how business works he doesn't
understand how private sector growth
happens he a good example neck is the
fact that he's got a stimulus plan he
calls it you know is what third or
fourth stimulus plan he says you know
the way we're going to
this kind of move again is to hire more
teachers and firefighters and policemen
now does anybody aside whether that's a
good idea does anybody really believe
that the problem with the US economy is
we don't have enough firefighters and
policemen I mean it just completely
ignores the role of the private sector
in terms of how you get businesses to
grow a private sector is doing fine
right we know that for sure right but so
then how now Romney comes in and Romney
has great the private sector bona fides
what is he or I mean on a certain level
if you're right that it's a referendum
on the incumbent he can be silent and
this he gets a lot of criticism for not
really articulating a positive vision
but what should he be doing or anybody
to get the private sector going I met
Ronnie I think he has a fundamental flaw
I think he suffers from guilt you know
he has incredible wealth he's been an
incredibly successful businessman he's a
turnaround artist that is this asset
when you ask me what is the single most
compelling case for Mitt Romney I'd say
it's his resume look at this guy he's a
success at everything he touched and
we're a country where a country that
needs a turnaround right I mean
Charlie's like they were a country and a
government that needs a turnaround and
yet the conundrum is that his asset is
being a turned into a liability by the
Obama forces through this kind of PR
campaign oh he's an outsourcer he's got
offshore accounts and Romney has been
miserable in responding to that there's
why doesn't he just stand up and give a
speech and defend the wealth creation
process look sometimes they took over
businesses and they failed sometimes
they succeeded you know this Nick two
out of every three small business in
America fail you know some enterprises
work others don't to look at his
failures and say you know he was a
failure was like saying you know Ted
Williams wasn't that great of a hitter
six out of ten times he went to the
plate he didn't get up hit so what is
the you know for you Steve Moore what
what is the one thing that the
government can do you know starting
tomorrow that would help the economy
settle and you know it actually grow
mama if I were advising Barack Obama I
am not the one thing he could do right
now that actually would help the economy
a lot would be to cancel tax McGavin
this is a big problem for the economy
think about this we're six months away
from this no businessman no investor no
work who knows what the tax system is
going to be like [ __ ] I mean how
dysfunctional is that really you think
the Republicans would go along if he
said hey you know what I'm just going
we're going to keep taxes exactly the
way they are for three years or even for
one year with the Republicans would they
get flummox by that or I think would put
them on the defensive look I I one of
the reasons I'm optimistic is I think
actually 2013 because our tax code is
such a train wreck and you've got the
expiring bush tax cuts give the
alternative minimum tax about the estate
tax you've got all of these prop the
carpet tacks which even liberal
democrats agree we can't go forward with
the highest corporate tax rate in the
world I think next year thus hours may
finally be in line to just blow up the
whole tax system and it's not fixable it
is not a fixable to we gotta stop
tinkering with it we got to fix it once
for i'ma I'm an old Steve Forbes guy I
would go with the old of the flat tax of
nineteen percent and by the way if you
do that you're injecting rocket fuel in
this economy well we'll leave it there
Steve more of the Wall Street Journal
thanks so much for talking to reason TV
thank you Nick I love watching recent TV
and what you guys do is just fabulous
well thank you so much for reason TV I'm
Nick cholesterin